morton collège de trappes
vous êtes devenu vieux mais un solde net
j'ai deux bouts on était des enfants
quand elle est partie je me demande
quelle est devenu commandes à ma mère
molly ne sort pas quels mots c'est parce
qu'une fille comme toi fais dans ce
groupe qui vit chez mozilla fait les
maintenant elle est entier
la meurtrière
est ce que j'ai commis un meurtre
ils ont dit qu'elles avaient tué à cars
sont voûtées aller quand tu es parti je
me suis enfui à londres milan et paris
il ya deux choses qui ont pu être amenés
ici l'envi de danger ou moi
tu as d'entrée samedi soir je pourrais
être confectionné une robe c'est pas une
robe qui va changer les choses
tu te trompes gertrude ouvre grand les
yeux
je peux faire de toi la plus sexy fille
de la danse enlève tes vêtements
meurtrière et une lesbienne
stupéfiant
tu as appris à transformer les gens
utilisent seulement
tilly donetsk
ce que tu te rappelles le jour là elle
avait toute la salle
je sais qu'elle a dit est maudite je
n'ai pas tué document est bourré aux
anges
ils me pardonneront jamais l'amour tous
car sans
tu perds ton temps ici
d'abord arrêter là
quoi cette racine
pourquoi tu m'a rien dit
tu ne t'es pas peur tilly d'un match
l'institut a enrichi toute ma vie
je suis persuadé que tu pourrais rendre
un homme parfaitement
tu dois être mariés dans ce costume fera
qu'à choisir entre la vieille fille et
la vieille folle